we have a major fundraising deadline  coming up no you don't no you this is  the biggest scam we have a deadline it's  a self-imposed deadline we've got to get  5 000 new donors by midnight tonight no  you don't you're just desperate dude and  there's never been a time like this our  country has never been so disrespected  our country has never been so low  certainly in the minds of others and  especially the leaders of other  countries all over the world yeah we  have to change it we have to bring our  country back we made it remember opinion  of the United States around the world  has dramatically improved since Donald  Trump left office every single poll  proves that America great and now we're  going to have to make America great  again yeah so I say whatever you can do  help out we have to meet the deadline  the midterms are coming up